it's been a long time since Leonardo
Donatello Raphael and Michelangelo
appeared on the big screen so there's a
lot of catching up to do here's
everything you need to know about the
upcoming teenage mutant ninja turtles
mutant Mayhem
[Music]
it's been seven years since Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles Out of the Shadows
arrived on movie screens in June 2016.
after that film was met with middling
reviews fans of the franchise would have
to wait until summer 2023 to see another
feature film originally teenage mutant
ninja turtles mutant Mayhem was slated
for an August 11 2023 release however in
January 2021 Paramount Pictures
announced quite a few changes to the
Studio's schedule after emerging from
the pause and Theatrical exhibition
brought on by the covid pandemic with
many major titles like the Mission
Impossible movies getting new release
dates mutant Mayhem was one of the many
films to get pushed around fortunately
for Turtles fans will now get to see the
film significantly sooner currently the
movie will hit theaters on August 2nd
2023 however mutant Mayhem will only
have two days free of box office
competition before the Meg 2 the trench
surfaces on August 4th both will duke it
out at the box office for a couple of
weeks until they receive further
theatrical competition from another
young hero in the form of DC Comics Blue
Beetle this new superheroes live action
debut will be released on
18th teenage mutant ninja turtles mutant
Mayhem will focus on the early days of
the turtle's crime fighting career as
they navigate the Big Apple and try to
show everyone the heroic intentions not
only do they want to be accepted as
Heroes but they seek affirmation and
acceptance as normal teenagers hey guys
if we weren't monsters that were shunned
by society and we could do what we
wanted
[Music]
what would you guys do
somehow the path they choose to normalcy
involves taking down mutant Crime Boss
Superfly of course the turtles meet a
new friend along the way in the form of
April O'Neil a human teenager who
becomes a group's most trusted partner
in fighting crime the four half-shelled
brothers in April find themselves
completely out of their element when
Superfly unleashes a dangerous mutant
Army upon New York City with the
intention of eliminating all humans to
save their Hometown the turtles their
ingenious friend and Master Splinter
must save the entire city from mutated
villains of all shapes some of those
menacing mutants will include the likes
of Bebop and Rocksteady Leatherhead
Genghis frog Mondo gecko Wing nuts and
the mad scientist Baxter Stockman will
they beat too much for the turtles to
handle well we're assuming our ninja
buddies will get the job done but the
movie is definitely emphasizing their
youth and inexperience it seems the
filmmakers are really trying to
highlight the teen element of our
protagonists in this installment
teenage mutant ninja turtles mutant
Mayhem boasts an A-list cast with
veteran actors and comedians filling out
many of the supporting Parts but before
we start looking at Side characters who
will be playing The star-throwing
side-wielding Mask wearing Turtles
Nicholas Cantu is playing the leader of
the group Leonardo if you're a fan of
The Amazing World of Gumball his voice
will definitely sound familiar to you as
he played Gumball himself in season 5
and 6. the brainy Donatello is voiced by
Micah Abby who plays Leaf in
Nickelodeon's cousins for Life the
wisecracking Michelangelo is portrayed
by Shaman Brown Jr who previously
starred as Stanley Papa Jackson in the
chief finally the gruff Rafael is voiced
by Brady noon who played Evan morrow in
the Mighty Ducks game changers
as for the rest the legendary Jackie
Chan plays Master Splinter the turtle's
rodent Mentor ioe debris of the bear
portrays April O'Neil Our Hero's human
Ally Seth Rogan and John Cena will voice
iconic big baddies Bebop and Rocksteady
while their fellow mutants will be
voiced by Hannibal Burris as Genghis
frog Rose Byrne is Leatherhead and Paul
Rudd is Mondo gecko post Malone plays
The Aquatic Ray filet Natasia dimitro of
what we do in the shadows will keep
things batty as Wingnut and Giancarlo
Esposito will voice mad scientists and
long time Turtle foe Baxter Stockman
some movies would be content to cast
Bebop and Rocksteady opposite the
turtles maybe throw in a shredder scene
and call it a day teenage mutant ninja
turtles mutant Mayhem however is going
much deeper in addition to bringing back
a bunch of classic TMNT villains like
Leatherhead and Baxter Stockman mutant
Mayhem is introducing at least two new
characters to the franchise the first is
the Ice Cube voiced Superfly
tortoises huh this mutant fly is a
film's overarching villain an organizer
of all the other vengeful mutants in the
Seth Rogen produced animated film in
addition to Ice Cube actress Maya
Rudolph has apparently joined the cast
in the role of Cynthia utron while the
utroms may be familiar to Turtles fans
Cynthia is a brand new character we
haven't seen or heard from her at all in
the early trailers so we aren't exactly
sure what form Rudolph's character will
take however in the TMNT Universe the
utroms are the alien species that the
enemy warlord crane belongs to perhaps
this is a hint at who the villain of a
potential sequel could be
as the trailer for mutant Mayhem proudly
proclaims the film comes from the
permanent teenager Seth Rogen as a
movie's co-producer Rogan is best known
for writing directing and playing
goofballs and acclaimed comedies like
Superbad Pineapple Express and this is
the end Rogan has also produced quite a
few of his films alongside Evan Goldberg
and James Weber who join in here as
co-producers going into mutant Mayhem
Rogan has expressed interest and
focusing on the inherent Coming of Age
aspects of the franchise he explains a
collider that he always found the
Adolescent aspects of the mutant Heroes
to be the most interesting part of their
story he elaborated that the franchise
being centered around teens made this
project a perfect match for him saying
as someone who loves teenage movies and
who's made a lot of teenage movies and
who literally got their start in their
entire profession by writing a teenage
movie the idea of kind of honing in on
that element was really exciting to us
Rogan certainly approached the nearly 40
year old franchise with a fresh mindset
even Ninja Turtles co-creator Kevin
Eastman admits he's pretty psyched to
see the film telling IGN that he really
enjoys Rogan's work and he's curious to
see how he approaches the new movie
with Seth Rogen and Evan Goldberg
producing you might be wondering who's
directing mutant Mayhem the job of
shepherding the turtles to the big
screen has gone to Jeff Rowe who
co-wrote Netflix's the Mitchells versus
the machines he's also served as a
writer on both Gravity Falls and
disenchantment proving he's quite Adept
at mastering the medium of Animation
mutant Mayhem is Rose directorial debut
and while praising the film's production
designer on Twitter Roe wrote the colors
are cool and unexpected we wanted to
throw out the animation Playbook on this
one based on the visuals we've seen it
looks like mutant Mayhem will stand
alongside the aforementioned Mitchells
versus the machines and Spider-Man into
the spider-verse when it comes to
incredible designs Rose also compared
the film to some coming-of-age Classics
Italian Empire that his team had films
like Stand By Me and ladybird in mind
when they were coming up with it
speaking about the turtles themselves he
said they've got a lot of that
inauthentic confidence that teenagers
have when you're a teen you don't know
any better so you operate with this
hyped up sense of we can do anything
I'm awesome as for who wrote the script
Rogan and Goldberg All Share Credit
alongside Dan Hernandez and Benji samit
the verse trailers for Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles Mutant Mayhem features the
classic hip-hop song can I kick it by A
Tribe Called Quest this Choice can help
it evoke 1991's Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles number two The Secret of the
Ooze soundtrack which featured Vanilla
Ice's ninja rap however there appears to
be more to the mutant Mayhem soundtrack
than just 90s rap according to the
film's director in one Rogue celebrity
Trent Reznor and Atticus Ross of Nine
Inch Nails have been tapped to score
mutant Mayhem and a funny Twist of Faith
the news actually came out after
skateboarding legend Tony Hawk let it
slip while being interviewed on a
podcast mutant Mayhem director Jeff Rowe
took to Twitter to get on top of the
league and announce the official
collaboration with Reznor and Ross on
May 28th Roe wrote well now that my
teenage hero Tony Hawk is leaked at my
music heroes are doing this I can add
that the score is absolutely amazing
exhilarating terrifying heartbreaking
full of sounds I didn't know existed
it's unclear how much of the soundtrack
to Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles Mutant
Mayhem will be resner and Ross's
original were and how much will be
licensed songs from artists in the vein
of can I kick it if we had to guess we'd
say there will likely be a little bit of
bull but maybe that's Wishful thank you
while you're waiting for mutant Mayhem
you may want to catch up on previous
Turtle content and there's a lot
unfortunately the original Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles cartoon isn't
available to stream anywhere but you can
purchase it on iTunes if you want to see
the turtles in live action you can buy
Ninja Turtles the Next Mutation on
Amazon Prime bands of the 2003 Fox
series Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles can
check out all seven seasons on Paramount
plus well fans of the 2012 Nickelodeon
series can find three seasons on
Paramount plus and two on Netflix and if
you're looking for Rise of the Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles various seasons of
the series are available on Paramount
Plus at Netflix the first feature film
Trilogy to showcase the Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles is available to rent on
Amazon Prime Apple iTunes Google play
Voodoo and YouTube each of these
platforms also hosts the animated TMNT
film from 2007. finally the first
Michael Bay produced TMNT movie released
in 2014 is available to stream on Amazon
Prime and Paramount plus the second and
most recent film Out of the Shadows can
be streamed on Paramount Plus in Pluto
TV
so many different shows and movies about
the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles over
the years we get that it's hard for
anyone who's not a hardcore TMNT head to
understand where the newest animated
movie falls in the Canon luckily the
answer is surprisingly simple we are
starting with a clean slate and a brand
new decade for the turtles Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles Mutant Mayhem is
not a part of any existing TMNT timeline
the upcoming animated feature is a full
reboot to the franchise Seth Rogen and
Evan Goldberg's approach of exploring
the four turtles as modern teens
requires a full reset to their mythology
the vimer's art style also marks mutant
Mayhem as a distinctly new story with
new interpretations on the characters
fans have known and loved since the
1980s mutant Mayhem might be a fresh
start but there's a high likelihood it
won't be the only animated turtles in
this continuity if the movie succeeds
Paramount has already hinted that it may
want more animated films from this
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles franchise
teenage mutant ninja turtles mutant
Mayhem doesn't hit theaters until August
2nd but there are already Whispers that
this stylish new take on the turtles is
the start of a new animation initiative
at Paramount in 2022 variety s Paramount
chief executive officer Brian Robbins
about the plans for rebooting the TMNT
series Robbins replied it's going to
work for kids parents gen's ears and
Millennials we have plans to do multiple
animated movies this way but one day we
might go back to a hybrid live-action
version of the turtles this statement
shines some light on the future of the
franchise while still being
frustratingly vague Robbins teased a
return to live action Turtle movies but
definitely implied that if mutant Mayhem
succeeds it will Garner sequels the
praising is nebulous enough that Robbins
is really only committing to more
animated movies in this modern Sony
pictures animation inspired style
regardless of how you want to interpret
Robin's statement if mutant Mayhem
connects with audiences it sounds like
you can expect there to be more animated
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles movies in
the future
[Music]
thank you